we are not the aggressors in the culture
war i
have had the distinction
over the past two days
of being condemned not just by one but
by two
american universities
isn't that amazing
one of those universities
is bu
i spoke at bu
a couple of weeks ago a few weeks ago i
gave a talk and
the the bu administration really tried
to shut this thing down so i had a sold
out crowd and then there were people who
had shown up for a
standby line because there was some talk
that there might be a kind of a walk out
then for whatever reason it was the
police chief or the deputy police chief
there was there was one guy generally
the people we worked with at this event
were very nice and very accommodating
but there was this one dude i think it
was the deputy chief who just wouldn't
let people in wouldn't let half the
audience in wouldn't let our
photographer in we couldn't even get
photographs of the event made the
standby line disperse and and sabotaged
the event
and then at one point a bunch of the
libs in there stood up and yelled and
screamed and they sort of walked out too
and then
they wouldn't let anyone come back in so
it was a bit of sabotage but we at least
got the speech out and now the the bu
student government has just issued a
formal
condemnation of me
said we're disappointed and frustrated
by the boston university
administration's allowance of a speaker
who is openly transphobic
and actively seeks to erode and endanger
the lgbtq community
students expressed their concerns about
safety and the bu administration
continued to be silent and allowed for
the event to occur we fully believe in
freedom of speech and expression however
there you go there's that however
however not for michael however there is
a line between free speech and hate
speech that must be drawn okay
obviously written by not
very well-educated undergraduates
they accuse me of being transphobic
a phobia is an irrational fear of
something i don't have any
fear of
people who have strange sexual confusion
i certainly don't have any irrational
fear of that i'm simply making the
observation that men are not women and
boys are not girls and that it is wrong
for a society to pretend otherwise
because it's a lie and it's a delusion
and it doesn't help anybody not the
people who are confused not the rest of
society that has to pretend and be made
to lie we just shouldn't tolerate that
because it's just not true
regardless of what you think about the
transgender issue
my view is not the extreme one
my view is not the radical one
my view that men can't secretly be women
is the view held by
statistically all human beings
everywhere throughout the entire history
of the world until five seconds ago
the view that men secretly can be women
and are women and we should treat them
as such
that is the extreme view that is the
radical view that is the aggressive view
in the cultural war now i expect this
kind of thing
from boston university
bu is a liberal school in a liberal town
in a liberal state
okay i'm not terribly surprised but it
gets even crazier because we just found
out a couple of days ago
that another university had invited me
to speak
and the school itself the school
administration preemptively shut it down
and the school
was not some radical secularist school
it's not supposed to be it was a
catholic school
and they took issue with me
for holding the catholic view
of sex and and gender and human nature
this school is
the university of saint thomas in
minnesota
and
the school said
this was the university
and the student government so the
university leaders and the student
government said that they would not
permit the student group to bring me to
campus
because i had made comments on
transgender issues that the university
had deemed were in violation of the
quote commitment to dignity and
diversity
and mike what is my comment by the way
they're trying to insinuate that i'm i'm
really insulting or mean or cruel to
people or that i'm calling for violence
against people i haven't done anything
of the sort of course that's why they
never cite any examples here they just
use this vague term that i'm i'm
undermining their dignity and i'm saying
phobic sort of things what is my view
what is the view that is contrary to the
values of the university of saint thomas
my view is that men and women are
different and complementary my view is
the catholic view where did i get my
view the catechism of the catholic
church would be one source if the
university of saint thomas is so shocked
and offended by what i have to say
can you even imagine what will happen
when they read st thomas oh boy fellas
you're really in for something when you
read st thomas aquinas at the university
of saint thomas because his views gosh
they're even more blunt and direct and
eloquent than mine are aren't they
it's it's always bad
when conservatives are not allowed to
say conservative things on campus that's
bad and sad and shows you how far the
campuses have fallen
but it is especially absurd when a
catholic is not allowed to say catholic
things at a catholic university
but it's obviously not a catholic
university they're admitting that now
they are saying no we there are
between the two religions that we've got
to pick catholicism
and secular liberalism
we're going to choose secular liberalism
a man cannot serve two masters
university of saint thomas i think
they're they're circulating a petition
now to bring me to speak
i'm happy to speak i'd like to go you
know since the student group invited me
that would be very nice but
much more importantly than that whether
i speak or not i don't i don't really
care ultimately i speak on lots of
college campuses
what is very important here is we have
to expose the administration of the
university of saint thomas this is
scandalous the bishops should get
involved because this is a catholic
university the parents who are writing
their tuition checks should get involved
here this is a true scandal
if if the if a catholic university isn't
going to teach basic facts about the
difference between men and women then
what are they they're teaching nothing
but extreme radical leftism
that it's dangerous for me to go to a
school and say boys and girls are
different that's apparently dangerous
but when the libs are calling for the
assassination of conservative supreme
court justices that's fine i'm not
exaggerating that by the way the the
liberal group that sent the the mobs to
the justices homes they did not
explicitly call for physical violence
they heavily insinuated it by saying we
want a diversity of tactics
peaceful protesting is fine but we want
a diversity of tactics okay we want you
to go to their homes where their
families live they were heavily
insinuating it some blue czech libs came
right out and said it
there's this one guy
simon gwynne
you can tell he's a good person because
he has the ukraine flag in his twitter
name he's calling to assassinate
american supreme court justices but he's
got the ukraine flag so he's a good he
probably wore the mask too so he's a
good guy simon gwynne blue checkmark he
says interesting real-life trolley
problem in america right now if you had
the chance to kill clarence thomas and
samuel alito the two oldest right-wing
supreme court justices would you
should you do it while biden can get his
nominees to replace them confirmed
he then goes on and and he says it's
interesting as an abstract question but
becomes a real conundrum if say you're
terminally ill and have little to lose
yourself but know that it could save
many women's lives in the future so he's
not even saying gosh what should we go
out and just kill the judges
i don't know i'm just asking questions
he goes even further than that he says
you know especially if you don't have
that much to lose and these judges
they're killing women somehow that i'm
not exactly explaining how
should you he's saying it should you
do the thing that i'm suggesting is a
good thing and kill
supreme court judges
says the good man with a nice flag in
the blue check mark
i'm so glad you like that clip now
ring that bell smash that like click
that subscribe i don't know whatever the
lingo is make sure you get all the
notifications also head on over to the
michael knowles showed apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you